citizens of the reject Nation it's me Tera
Ericson alongside my friend Batman sorry
what's your real name it's Bruce Wayne oh
that's a good name too but tell them your
real name okay Andrew Flash Gordon a that's
such a cool name we're going to watch Now You
See Me Do you see me right now no where are you
oh there you are somewhere better than this I'll
tell you that much listen you got to leave a
like you got to type in the computer you got
to leave comments you guys so that people think
we are cool and you also have to ring the bell
ring the bell yeah you got to get on our side
ring that Bell also if you're not already on
patreon you need to get on there because then
you can sync up with your full copy watch the
whole thing with me and Batman right here the
whole entire movie you know you you might miss
stuff if you're not on patreon you get the whole
thing like stuff that we're saying like M and A's
and I don't know jokes that may maybe didn't
make the cut you know what I mean might miss
some references from me yes and he he has a
lot almost too many sometimes I'm might close
the book for a second you know it's a lot he can
fire a lot at you so get prepped okay guys don't
forget that GRE and John covers several shows
over there on patreon exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included so just
get to patreon you guys know what's good for
you are you ready so ready okay want to see some
magic yeah Now You See Me Now you don't here we
go come in close because the more you think
you see the easier it'll be to fool you did
you see one yes now do you see your card
here no that's because you're looking too
closely what is making it rain with cards I guess
so oh that's cool oh that's awesome
nice that was amazing now look into my
eyes and you can get this bill from me you can
have it get it if you can say your name you can
have why can't anyone play this game with me
you're thinking of a woman's name a b c d e f
g h i j Jean Jane Janet who's Janet uh what
it's not your best friend is he your sister
pleas Bo buddy you were away on Janet your wife
sister okay what is this uh 200 seem fair you
know what this is a big deal let's go 250 you're
a stickup artist andle now when I snap my fingers
you won't remember any of this right in the
middle of everywhere too and think of Janet
you're going to picture me naked and that's not a
pretty s yeah and wide awake he didn't even need
a room for that we did the best we could but
some people just wanten to be hypnotized I did
it wrong oh no you did it fine did good I mean
I'm 250 bucks uh cheap less than my wallet but
we did fine $100 anyone who can tell me how this
trick is done I have an ordinary spoon from Mel's
Deli right here in Brooklyn check it out there
is no spoon I'm about to bend this spoon with my
mind how thank you thank you around this what
are you doing uh I got other trick or you can
give me my 100 bucks you have a very good eye
sir thanks yeah but he didn't say you could
physically touch me he said to tell me yeah
man get the rules right bro oh dang love it
score he is a magician after all that guy
in the Le Jack he's got my wallet that's
awesome I mean I'm not for thievery but that
was awesome I'm all for thievery zero a tank
full of fles eating piranhas will fall
from above a lady has to have handcuffs
right girl oh I love her who hey girl hey my
God those guys looked way too excited just to
see a girl in like a bathing [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] suit ah oh she serious she can't get
up get ever since the prestige I don't
I don't like these kinds of scenes what
the H feel like it's part of the act but
I can't tell yeah I can't tell [Music]
either what what what what what
what how you going to escape
that no oh that's going to be crazy to
escape that she's escaping I'm telling
you this is this is great this is
a great stunt yeah no she's for
sure escaping whoever say us
oh that was awesome oh my God
spooky oh my so hard oh thank you
is it always a seven I can do that
trick 52 different ways can you do 52
different tricks on me I'll see what I can
do who hold on
what 45 east7 no don't don't worry about it
I I'll call you you don't have my number a
magic I'll find it have a good night it's like
look for my number on the side of a building h
yeah well we got our roster of group of magicians
ah somebody want to kill these magicians what's
this card stuff about I'm assuming the card
that they all have is from that person in
the hood oh yes who's just been lurking around
just watching them inspecting them making sure
they're all worthy of of being magicians I didn't
know you had to be worthy of that you're going to
join the club whosoever holds this Hammer
if he be worthy shall possess the power of
th oh all right can she reach in there bring them
all together Danny her name's Henley you wait out
here I will come back and get you okay do not
come in hey Danny not your assistant anymore
nice hair okay so apparently none of us was
the only one chosen let me be the first one
to kick my ego to the curb you now hold it
don't tell me uh Helen no no Henley it's on
your coffee cup thanks for keeping me honest
sensing you are a control freak well I take
that as a compliment only he would take it as
a compliment good another compliment that's why
you're no longer a couple no no we never never
a couple is this foreshadowing they're going to
end up married at the end of the movie I I see
it Daniel Atlas do I have seen everything that
you have ever done I mean you're like I idolize
you seriously a true fan it's so nice to meet
you we we waiting for someone why why are we just
door locked oh no nothing nothing's ever locked
who's behind the door the oracle yeah what's
going on here perect guy to have that was so
fast what's it say it's a test now
you don't H aose By Any Other [Music]
Name oh what the oh it's going to
fill up that little thing on the
floor
who electricity is out oh let's check feels
like it's out of a saw movie yeah it kind of
does blueprints okay this doesn't look like
magic it looks like engineering and [Music]
math huh roll credits the end
that was a good movie oh so
good Meritt mckin oh Daniel
Atlas Henley Reeves Jack Wilder The Four
Horsemen oh all right we're going to do
something never before seen on a
Las Vegas stage or any stage for
that matter that's a humongous crowd
yeah and a giant stage we are going to
rubber Bank cool that's funny I've seen
that done once in a Batman the Animated
Series episode with zatana really they did
that yeah something along the lines of that
yeah Morgan Freeman oh I didn't know he
was in this no recording allowed during
the performance oh yeah yeah sure cool let me
just put this away actually I need to take that
okay oh dude the same kind of trick in the
Dark Knight and Jack B are ping pong balls
with Section number jack can you hand me a
section number thank you we are looking at
section B I want to go to this show seriously
it's not the same show but this makes me sad I
never got to see sik freed and Roy oh yeah
we are looking at row number five where is
that and uh Henley can I please have a random
seat number lucky number 13 b513 is it going to
be Morgan Freeman or oh no ah there you
are hi my name Isen forier and my bank
it's can you please come up to the stage
we'll uh Rob your bank there is someone
here tonight without whom we would just be
four magicians working the circuit they Mr
Arthur Trester please stand up Arthur the only
man here with the queen cell phone hey M Kane
I love him damn they got Alfred and lucious Fox
here my cocaine we haven't done our closer yet
why you watch it and then you can decide for
yourself oh he's doing his hypnotic trick on
him oh interesting what Jack is bringing to
the stage now is what we in the Magic World
teleportation helmet crazy this is it will
allow you to literally to your bank it has
the added attraction of being very stylish it's
about time the French learn from America on that
subject you can take that one okay there you
go now show to your friends in section B there
but but not to us card we started the movie out
with put it in your pocket and now for one tiny
detail but oh my God how'd she do
that get out of here whoa all right
cool that's 8:50 a.m. in Paris your
bank opens in less than 10 minutes 1 2
3 oh my God that's terrifying I like
that little French guy where'd he
go no really oh my god there he is how I want
you to take the card that you signed out of
your pocket and I want you to take the ticket St
from tonight's show and I want you to put it right
there in the middle of the money huh now drop
it that the smartest thing to do no it's like oh
to say he robbed his own bank right like yeah on
the side of your helmet you should feel a button
activates an air duct that connects Paris to to
Las Vegas okay good now you can press [Music] it
what oh wait a second is it all going to
Vegas and they're going to open that thing
money just going to start falling out
uhoh I'm [Music] out what what that's
insane that's great but they're just all
allowed to take money that they know was
part of a robbery I mean it's a cool trick
don't get me wrong but they visually saw a
robbery I would take it I'd be like The Magicians
did it it was still a cool trick don't again do
not mistake it thank you everyone we are the
four Hors and good night good night but that
not again visual of a crime even if it was
in another country that's crazy that's nuts
is that is that Mark Ruffalo yes it is we got
a lot of comic book actors in this movie did
you just say magicians yeah D magicians where
are you now I'm in Arya I'm heading up there to
grab him now another comic book actor he's in
Man of Steel I can see him let's go get him up
come on minut do one of you guys mind giving us a
h with our bags okay so this is like one big long
setup they plan this they want to go to jail
yeah I mean yeah you you don't just show off
a robbery like that unless you're play I mean
I assume they had like I don't know that they
were going to be like I'm a month two tops away
for blowing this whole thing open another comic
book actor I don't know have time for this
magic crap this crap just pulled 3 million e
out of a Parisian bank that's how much they got
actually 32 alre from inel it's bad enough they
got me chasing down David Copperfield he believes
the magic was real oh he believes the magic was
real you're right he probably us useless is it
okay with interpole if we talk to him too thank
you can you explain to me how you went from
Las Vegas to Paris in 3 seconds with reputation
helmet he was hypnotized during the show I'll
deal with you when I'm done with this other
[__] oh what come on down you're not philarmonic
how do you say stop in French stop you just have
to let him finish his movement okay I need a
time out I didn't know like hypnotism could
last like a long long time yeah we can work
together or you can continue to follow the
be and asking the same exact questions I'm
asking it's up to you come on man Teamwork
Makes the Dream work also she's very pretty
you are a a mentalist tricks mostly um some
science uh targeted guessing might be a most
app description along with some intuition and
the occasional voices in my head I'm going to
look that up in the dictionary after we're done
if you didn't rob that bank then you knew about
it which makes you an accomplice so if you want
to walk out of here today you think there's
a DA in the state of Nevada who' be willing
to make sense of this to a jury then we have
a show to perform and you agent roads have a
drawing board to get back to they do make a
cute couple not going lie literally begging
to be arrested you know that if it means you would
actually do it then yeah but you won't because if
you did it means that you will actually believe
at an Institutional level in Magic and we'd be
even more famous than we already are and you guys
would look like idiots even more than you already
are don't draw him in and then dump him because
abandon is a big area for him mommy daddy I feel
like he's about to snap on him maybe that's his
plan because then he gets to touch him right
then he could then he could do a a trick on him
thing yeah hypnotizing we will always be one step
three steps seven steps ahead of you and just
when you think you're catching up that's will
be right behind you and at no time will you be
anywhere other than exactly where I want you to
be so come close the closer you think you are the
less you'll actually see I'm going to nail you oh
holy wrong with that soda M [Music]
tamale whoa oh my goodness first rule of magic
always be the smartest guy in the room that was
amazing that's awesome H I love all of it it's
going to say like what do you charged that doing
magic 3,000 M or however many miles away they were
right like how do you even how do you prove that
in court I ran a check on the audience but guess
who was sitting there in the back filming the
whole damn thing I don't know fadus Bradley the
guy from TV with the DVDs in the shows no is that
Morgan Freeman he debunks magicians he exposes
him he shows you how they do the trip oh okay so
yeah it is him L strike Midland magician my first
show I revealed all of his tricks a year later he
tried to the stage of combat had himself locked
in a safe and dropped to the bottom of the East
River the safe was never recovered he attempted
something he was Ill prepared to handle we were
about to do the same thing but I assure you Vegas
was just a start watch Michael Kane is going to be
a li just I'm just kidding we're trying to nail
the same guy so why don't you give us a hand now
why would I do that how about I just drag you
in right now on obstruction charges and force
you to tell me unless what you're actually read
really trying to say is is you don't have any
idea how they did it he has every idea how they
did it the real trick is happening somewhere else
I want to know how they robbed a bank you're an
idiot if you think they robbed a bank yeah with
the eyes see and the ears here the Mind believes
yeah misdirection at least that's what swordfish
told me step right up there you go what she's
going to turn to the Hulk how do he get access
I was about to just ask ask how does he and
how let know how to like they're like we're
nitpickers oh it's just like below the stage
and it looks like uh that's great so they made
a replica personally preferred to take the
stairs so they picked they picked that guy
from the stage way beforehand yeah got it
that's awesome okay that makes more sense
they chose him they knew which seat he was in
no no no the audience picked the seat he let
them think they picked the seat actually they
were just pming the ball with the seat number
they wanted oh yeah okay could you just confirm
that this is in fact your seat he was selected
yeah but then they did the hypnotizing trick
too right they programmed his mind to make him
go to Las Vegas and then they kept reinforcing
it until he did oh nothing was left to chance
that's awesome I got his measurements wow H
and they simply activated him in yep but how
did they know what bank was his you're kidding
really can you be any more of a condescending
ass yes credit card and that's how they got the
signature for the card you said they didn't steal
the money no I didn't say they didn't steal the
money I said they didn't run the bank yeah my
guess is that they targeted a shipment of fresh
limited money headed to the Frenchman's Bank on
board an armored truck okay just as hard to
break into unless you're already inside M
oh God I really thought that was the greatest
magic trick of all time yeah for our Horsemen
it's almost too easy nice okay how do they make
the phony money disappear from The Vault flash
paper magicians use it all the time
huh grief no smoke leave nor to do I'm actually
really starting to believe my Michael cocaine
is Lyall guy cuz he's getting revenge on Morgan
Freeman I don't know I might be right on that so
what's under it for truster besides the money ego
okay pick your card look at it put it in the deck
and tmy no don't don't going to say just take away
the trick yeah these guys are a bunch of Street
magicians a year ago with no resources so how do
they go from doing that to this without some kind
of outside help is this so no my car's sitting
over there that guy's lap she kind of got it right
what I hate is people who exploit other people by
taking advantage of their weaknesses they need to
believe in something that's unexplainable is
this your card yeah is this a foreshadowing
for something she's going to do later on the film
meaning like she might be in on it at the or like
do me oh yeah you had a dog a real tough dog a
brutish breed like a real I want to say Ben the
Bulldog I had a fluffy white cat called snaffled
it's a good name for a cat you had an uncle on
your mother's side some kind of Paul Thomson was
it a Paul nearly though was I yeah my uncle's name
was kushman Armitage he should have went through
the alphabet you got an uncle then he needs to
do the a b c d e and watch for eye movement I
already know how to do it and I've only seen this
movie for 20 minutes he has every member of his
crew wearing a tracking bracel as long as Alice
is tracking them our boys can track Alice from
right here in the mobile command unit interesting
I'd be like yo am I at work or in prison what's
up with his ankle bracelet well remember at the
first show no one was allowed to have cell phones
there yeah it's like very controlled environment
totally do I really think it's possible there's
a fifth Horseman yeah fifth Horsemen is that what
you just said oh yeah huh there is a legend of
a secret Aura born in ancient Egypt called the
eye it is said they perfected slight of hand to
steal food he's got such an epic voice I know
it's the best him and James Earl Jones yes using
magic and illusion to even the scales of Justice
are the horsemen next in a long line of fools to
believe this myth H according to your potential
backers you stand to make 2 and A2 million
tops from your best special damn 3 and a half
million ah you're in this to ride them up I'm in
a ride them down I take it that we do not have a
deal I would take that deal this isn't the first
time I've been threatened it is however the first
time you've been threatened by me one who uses a
doll to enact one's own wrath is likely to bring
that very wrath unto himself yeah and I thought
you didn't believe in magic I don't like it when
Alfred and Lucius don't get along it does make
sense though that like when someone who is so
rich like even if they're in the wrong they can
just pile on pile on people and like lawyers in
court cases I mean it's so unfair I know it's
like it's so frustrating which is why money
gives you so much power power yeah I always love
that line with Bruce Wayne where they said what's
your superpower I'm rich Jack Wilder Henley Reeds
Meritt mckin and Daniel Atlas The Four Horsemen
all right whose Bank are they going to rob Bo
this time look as closely as possible because the
tricks you are about to see may not seem connected
but we assure you they are and now for one of the
oldest tricks in the book oh the rabbit little
bunny fle down down sleep sleep we are going
to debunk a few magic myths this evening we all
know that fluffy is in fact alive and well a as
has the mirror which makes the Box only appear
as though it's your job is to tackle dismantle
the quarterback who's the quarterback waa that's
cool perfectly synced man yeah what is it when you
say uh you owe me a coke Jinx personal Jinx 1 2
35 ttimes 10 he will be the one saying that word
freeze whoa cool oh that's like a set oh what if
the quarterback is like more against Freeman or
they're trying to like no that's dope I want to
do that that does look fun I want to go fly in a
bubble yeah I would just suck if you're like
about 15 30 ft high in the bubble burst like
that some it's like a hero an insulting hero my
favorite kind yeah we ask you to write down your
current bank balance teal it in an envelope
velope now it's time to take those envelopes
out shout out your name all at once go why are
these people doing this I'd be like um none of
your business count from 1 to 10 out loud 1 2 3 4
5 is your bank balance $562 yeah why are you at a
magic show then yeah I mean you have every right
to you in Vegas period New Orleans oh shoot right
I mean she has every right to still be there but
probably be making some more money though she's
living her life yeah no no no of course hey go
to do whatever you want of course I'm just I'm
just saying she she's living on the edge man yeah
that's all that's all I was alluding to for sure
this evening would not be possible if it weren't
for our great benefactor Arthur Tres see are they
going to tackle him those people and they're going
to be like he's the quarterback and he stole all
their money I took a guess north of 140 am I right
that's 140 million oh my God how can he be right
about his balance and everyone else be wrong I
think possibly because he too is wrong he's the
quarterback like you said using the flashlight
under your seat start to warm up that paper I
think your correct balance begins to appear oh did
they all just get money we have a flashlight for
you yes oh my God his is now zero what is going
on now weird a second ago it said 144,50 79,513
70,000 less oh ah what is your new number oh guess
she can be there6 she can she can be there every
Friday baby heck yeah I mean she's still got more
work to do everyone in this room was a victim of
the hard times that hit one of America's most
treasured cities but all of you were insured by
the same company Insurance oh wolf got $882,000
on my bank account it it says it right here on
my cell phone everybody some cell phones right now
everybody damn I wish I could have went to a magic
show like this did you do this we'd need access to
information we could never get our hands on ah yes
security questions for instance like I don't know
your mother's made a name or or the name of your
first pet Snuffles you certainly would never
tell us uh oh oh my goodness [Music] wow oh
God this girl's like I'm out of here he's got
no money he's old I ain't with him [Applause]
anymore oh cuz he said free cuz he said
freeze the word was freeze no genius love
that I was so off on them tackling my
cocaine oh my God makes sense why they
would choose freeze cuz they knew he would
he would come after them the way that girl
just like starfish jumped on top of the
pile if anyone's at home and you want to
stop rewind and rewatch that it's hilarious
that was great I want everyone on the street
everyone do you think they took every single
Dollar in his bank account or left him I mean
they said they left him with the rose and
the and the jet I don't know right which
is why I'm like I feel like he had I mean
he does seem like he's freaking out but I'm
like is he also part of it like Michael
Kane like he knows like I don't know do
you think he's the fifth Horseman I'd have
no idea I'm like it's maybe but it's all
misdirect I don't yeah like or it could even
be his part I don't know we'll find out soon
enough uh yeah good luck oh oh is that
one of the tracking things yeah I think
so yeah he's never going to he's never finding
them that's just not happening am I wrong but
is this Marty gr or am I totally wrong it
looks like Marty yeah with the beads and
the colors and the celebration or maybe it's
just a regular Saturday night in New Orleans
you they like to [Music] party what are you
doing see like why did she hesitate yeah like
I'm like is she the fifth Horsemen and that's
why she was doing the cards on the plane like
is there but then I'm like nah why what would
this be like well they also did say this is her
first time on the field from a desk why is she is
she there as the you know the distraction pretty
French girl shows up out of the blue acts like
she's my partner and then she lets the bad guy
go who exactly are you anyway oh yeah see that's
where I'm like she doesn't seem like a magician
if she knows how to like jump over a fence
like that and all this other juice what is
this isn't there something about the eye at the
beginning remember yes like she's been studying
it still don't know about her I'm back and forth
on it Mr Bradley Mr Trestle would like you to join
him for a drink this makes me when I have a drink
in a hotel it's always a different vibe it's like
is that $3 million check still good this is a
magic trick you sir are the the distraction while
they set up the trick $140 million distraction
that's quite a distraction yeah whatever you
stand to make I'll double it you expose them now
and Destroy them you broke bro million have he
had 155 mil and they took 140 so I guess I would
leave him 15 unless I counted wrong yeah you're
right but was it Michael Kane who the person
in the hood is that person working for Michael
Kane or is that someone totally different cuz I'm
I'm a little lost there remember the person that
was scouting them at the beginning that's why I
was like he's on the plane right so that's cuz
then they started working for they went to that
apartment that I made a joke about is the Oracle
and that's the I feel like that they were working
for him and then that's how they got all his well
I don't know all of his well it's going to be
revealed at some point soon who's who they're
working with boy I sure hope so cuz we're really
jumping through hoops right now yeah we're like
so lost I'm sorry sorry for your arm it was
a drunk jerk I'm sorry I was a drunken [__]
yes I called it candidates for initiations must
follow a series of commands with blind obedience
the horsemen all of this is only to to join the
eye oh that apartment of the Oracle that's to
join that organization of whatever I think right
have you ever felt something that you can't see
but you know it's there got a little romantic
tension what you're feeling right now between
you and I whoa what someone has heard every call
read every text that's how they were able to stay
ahead of us God damn and they also stopped you
from having uh kissed too yeah play through H
stop zoom in tighter tighter there that's where
he took my phone put it back in and turn on the
phone they don't know that we know about the bug
as of this instant we are ahead of them that's
a good point yeah oh the firewalls down do they
know about this they who they them whoever we're
working for who are we working for that's what
we want to know yeah we'd love to know as well
watch it's going to be Morgan Freeman I'm
just kidding probably is Morgan Freeman I
just I don't know like so but this is good I
like that it's not predictable I like being
surprised I'm just literally throwing names out
in the wind right now seeing which one sticks
FBI
all right they just escaped where okay we're
curious what would they technically still
charge them on I mean from stealing from him
I guess right yeah exceedingly well how do you
like your horse shredded did they leave them a
little magical surprise in there oh just this
guy is that their next Target this
looks like all a setup right cuz
they were like they're here as though
they planned for obviously for them
I feel like they're always 10 steps
ahead of yeah of ah oh sneaky [Music]
business what is okay all right what no no no no
no oh my God where are these people learn to
fight you're just supposed to know magic come
here I didn't even see what just happened
oh my goodness what game you playing what
game you playing we're all good at 6 move
to seven wait what interesting how's he
doing that he's like a chameleon he can
just he needs to hear a couple things
he can be oh my God he got it I love him
but I'm not that good yeah flash paper him
out wa dude he's amazing what the heck it's an
Escape Artist this is awesome waa that's amazing
holy to Molly how do you fight against someone
like this you don't I'd be like I give up hold
on hold on hold on really yeah we're doing magic
oh ow oh yeah nope dang oh no I hate it ooh I'm
s I'm just not jumping in I'm not yeah here
we go baby give me that ooh right on top of
a nice dirty mattress that's always fun I'd
rather fall on top of a dirty mattress than
solid Crow though that's his every Sunday night
who told you fall on top of dirty mattresses
Sunday Mark ruffo's characters
had a bad couple days yeah also
who knew that these magicians also
know how to like fight are they like
they're also no Kung Fu and stuff
or whatever it is have plans for
everything DN she got up quickly
to him oh I was going to say New
York traffic this is uh yeah
forget about it kid there he
is damn
okay stay with them going to say after
his magician career is over you should
think about being a NASCAR driver or
just a kung fu fighter that too get
over I hate side seat drivers he is not
going to be in the car I'm telling you
he he's gone how we don't know
oh no he's there he's dead oh
wow oh God you guys better
get out of there it's going to
blow yeah oh whoa oh boy that was not expecting
that that really thought he was not going to
be in the car he's dead I can't even imagine the
awful traffic that would cause yeah is he really
dead though a magician just saying yeah don't
you find it peculiar that inapo will send you
a first timer off the desk to be your assistant
there's a sign in the case choosing a random card
in the deck he's getting in his head I feel like
I'm playing with somebody wearing ankle weights
keep up agent Rose I almost feel like he's in with
the mag see cuz that's why I what is going on it's
either like her or now I feel like it's like
Morgan is the fifth one yeah I think Morgan is
the I think he's the one who sent them the cards
and he's testing them he's yeah to see are they
worthy I think it's I think it's Morgan he's the
fifth Horseman I'm going with that this is the
part you're going to find particularly interesting
agent roads they passed to my server after they
accessed your mobile command that's got to hurt
I'm taking over [__] it's got a interesting
voice if we hope to capture the horsemen then
you need to have a little faith in me cuz I've
done nothing to all the wife I just got my ass
handed to me I think it's too I think it's too
obvious for it to be her yeah now I feel like
Morgan like set her yeah right like is setting
her up yeah he's definitely I think he's the one
who sent the cards that's like it's got to be I
don't know who else it could be there's like
is it just the mysterious person video taking
video of it all is him learning where they will
eventually lead to right they're what is this
where the hell is the goddamn safe sir you got
a phone call and said Washington wants the safe
mod you never heard that come out of my mouth
agent oh the chameleon guy they get the voices
[__] no what oh god oh he was hypnotized
oh this movie is insane team's loading the
truck oh that's great wow they're so good wow
what the hell's going on new orders open it up
so we stay with it wherever the safe goes we go
it'll lead us right to him misdirection yeah but
will it though now they have to know that like
the safe is yeah all right also yeah way to make
it not obvious by like with all the cop cars
following like what are we doing here this is
not discreet seriously remember the name Jack
Wilder when you see us live Five Points Queen
7:00 there shows in a half an hour it's exactly
where we're headed I don't want to be the nayir
but these guys are kind of tricky yeah God he's
finally G he's finally gaining respect for them
saying that you know he understands with these
guys they're not what they seem right meaning
like there's a reason they want all these
people to go there which is alas another
big distraction I presume we've got movement
someone's walking towards the truck is it
interpool no oh okay I'm following them just
like you are guess what I'm ahead of you now
if you want to look like even bigger idiots
why not open it the hell what give me that
oh boy that's awesome I love it get back one
big fat joke Ah that's great that's what you
guys were guarding they have you chasing empty
safes again w once again this Direction that's
what we said yeah we've been saying it
the whole time man don't listen to us
wow oh this is the Lego thing remember
how there was a Lego at the apartment yeah
yeah that is such a that's the scope of that crowd
that sick W that so cool that looks awesome how do
they do what do you imagine if you were on asset
watching this I'd be in a hole crying oh my God
it is about belief Faith trust but what happens
if these qualities are not used for their higher
purpose it's gr you're going to help us set
a few things right H wow they're going in the
wrong direction and you know it the got I got you
back always going the wrong way wrong direction
yeah never learn even if there is no I if we
were completely played and we spend the next
20 years in jail then I just want to say that I
know me too too sentimental for me they're too
cool to go to jail yeah man just saying they're
too entertaining to go to jail also they know how
to break break through it all they get keys
through soda pops I mean these guys we just
we don't [Music] know oh oh that's awesome that's
great did you guys really think it'd be that easy
yeah it's just like yes we are going to reveal
exactly where we'll be standing come and get
us are they on the other roof okay thank you for
being such an incredible and dedicated audience
so we wouldd like to start our show tonight by
saying goodbye now you see me oh who okay for us
to disappear what the are they whoa no those are
projected people whoa oh my goodness yes that's
awesome is that Mike cocaine's money oh no he
gave that away already too [Music] late godam like
dude why are you crumpling that put in your pocket
yeah I'd be taking it all so I guess this is it is
it oh wow okay she went in for the kill he's like
oh wow I should lose all my cases and insult my
partners I can see why she was into him I mean he
insulted her whenever he could he questioned her
I mean what what would you not want oh where's the
real money is this our fifth Horseman is it in the
back of this oh my goodness oh they set up Morgan
Freeman oh nice that's what you get for trying to
expose us yes for trying to expose magicians and
so Ah that's great that's great so it was all just
like a ploy to like get money also reel him in
knowing that he would be following them but also
why else I still want to know who was in charge of
the oh was that Lyall guy that went into the safe
but maybe it it wasn't Michael cocaine but who is
that ly guy cuz at the beginning remember Morgan
Freeman said that ly guy he exposed him he is he's
still alive my opinion I just want to know who he
is I'm been framed I'm sure you are yeah but I can
prove it remember the rapid trick in the second
show the box was never empty the room wasn't
either what oh transformed the whole room into
a giant rabbit box you drop your guard and leave
oh with the mirror oh damn that's brilliant wow
brilliant is that is that did he survive is that
what's his name it looks like him Dave Franco's
character oh my God that is so much money yep he
survived how did he survive that accident it's
locked weren't you listening nothing's ever
locked well done Mr Wilder he's the greatest
escape artist ever he escaped in a standard FBI
vehicle right yeah you to the bridge where the
other horsemen were waiting with an identical
replacement oh I only took a split second for
you to lose contact with it make the switch
wait oh wait how what oh my God and then that
is uh uhhuh okay damn that is amazing that's
awesome wow that is quite the plan to really
looking to Lono shrike the insurer who denied
fam's claim trest their insurance the bank that
carried the note credit Republican of Paris
okay now it's playing no it's not what if all
this was just leading up to us getting mugged in
Central Park at 2: a.m. no I'm telling you we're
right where we need to be oh remember that
thing she said about the tree growing in the
park for 20 years something like that the Lionel
shrike tree and the card encased in glass that's
right whoa that is so cool what I see
you that's awesome open SES oh the Is
It Michael K I don't know that was my
prediction early on but I don't know
and the FBI got past them not once not twice
consistently almost as if they were on the in
inside oh God it was Mark no are you kidding me
you what holy junk oh my God I did not see that
coming at all I want you to spend the rest of
your life in this cell how you let yourself be
so blinded by your ego that you convinced yourself
that you were one step ahead when you were always
two steps behind oh my God oh my goodness I did
not see that coming me me neither that was a
really good twist I'm not going to lie yeah like I
mean it was it was a really convincing Chase I did
not see that coming I me too he's speaking when
I said always be the smartest guy in the room we
were in agreement I was testing you I have always
been a 100% believer in the amount of energy I
have expended to keep these infidels on point
this is awesome this is a great twist Welcome
to the what what's going to happen what oh what
what it's a great twist but so he had to be an FBI
agent for all those years saying like how exactly
for him that was my main thing of like yeah but
he's part of the FBI where people know him and
trust him he's on a team that takes a lot of time
effort yeah it was all connected credit Republican
Trust insurance and elorn what's the connection
to Shri is that Elias cus elorn started as a safe
manufacturer they used cheap steel and when he got
to the bottom of the river the safe warped and he
was trapped he was your father oh was his dad oh
that's why he hates Morgan Freeman yep exposed his
dad The Logical conclusion for you to take this
case to its resolution and for you to turn me in
she like yeah that sounds right that I think some
things are best left unexplained one more secret
to lock away a that's cute so is he going to still
continue to be an FBI agent I mean I I think
yeah I guess you still got to keep it up right
yeah we are bonded forever with this lock on the
count of three open your eyes and tell me what you
see 1 2 okay oh oh it was Lis leer who directed
this this was the director of Incredible Hulk
it's funny that he oh yeah and that's why well
no um Mark Mark he wasn't the one but but but
fun fact even though Ed Norton was the Hulk in
that film he actually wanted Mark Ruffalo to be
the Hulk before yeah but they actually got Edward
Norton and then there was maor clash between Kevin
feige Marvel and Ed Norton so like yeah let's go
with Mark Ruffo cool that he finally got to work
with Mark Ruffo so um I'm always a sucker for
a great twist and again the whole I I do have
some questions about I mean I'd have to really
think about it more in terms of again you know
revenge is a is a Fickle matter and you know what
Morgan Freeman did to Mark ruffalo's father I can
understand wanting to hey I'm GNA have to come
up with some elaborate ploton scheme and I'm
going to have to join the FBI and then I'm going
to have to search out magician and skap part and
blah blah blah so I guess I could buy into this
again if I really thought way too hard on him I'd
probably come up with some logic of yeah this
plan's not going to work but I could probably
do that with a lot of movies that I love and just
you know what it was a great twist but again in
the comment section if you think I'm wrong and
say hey Andrew you're wrong it was a crap twist
that's cool um but I I liked it um I did not see
it coming yeah I didn't at all again I was under
the impression it was probably Michael Kane was it
was him or or the woman or maybe it was morganan
so again I really didn't see it as Mark Ruff so
I'm again I'm a sucker for a good twist and I
also just I'm also a sucker for magic in general
and I just loved all the uh just the uh just all
the magician stuff all the magic stuff it was just
it was really it was elaborate it was fun I just
I I just loved it oh it was great uh this was it
was a fun ride this movie what you think it was
a lot of fun I feel like him being 12 though and
carrying that Grudge throughout his entire life
is like wow that's tough I get that you would also
need many many years to think this through but I
also think like God life you get through like
high school and college and people come your
way and you're probably like uh how am I still
going to get I'm just Mark ruffo's character in
this I'm like you have a lot of resolve buddy the
fact from 12 until now and you carried it through
cool um the one scene that keeps like in my head
keeps messing me up is that when Morgan calls him
and tells him that girl was not a signed to you
she chose it right why why is she throwing off
your game that he so genuinely was like wait she
was she was assigned like she had to be on this
case right why would that that that's the only
thing that I'm like oh of course it would mess
him up maybe that one little detail but he really
worked he worked out the whole thing like he saw
the whole plan ahead of him so uh the phone call
thing was the main thing that threw me off from
that I think because he was so genuine about like
wait what do you mean this girl she could not and
then he yells at her being like I'm not asking you
I'm asking him um when I'm like yeah but the whole
time he was in on the entire thing right and he
didn't need to be mad in front of anyone else to
make the thing work right so um you know I'd be
interested too in a rewatch just like now that
we know the twist like looking at all the signs of
Mark Ruffalo because when you watch this in in the
first it really just before I accidentally spoil
it cuz I don't want to have you seen the film The
Fugitive with Tommy Lee Jones and Harrison Ford
yeah okay well I'm not going to spoil anyways
in that film Tommy Le Tommy Lee Jones is on the
hunt for Harrison Ford that's all I'm going to
say about that but it really felt like you know
that in a sense of Mark Ruffalo is really going
hunting them down and will do anything to stop
them and from that perspective I loved it and
like I would have never ever that's why I never
would have guessed the twist in this in terms of
like that no he's the one who hired them in
the beginning right and he's putting in all
that effort yeah which was great and then also too
like he's ridiculing the interpole woman and he's
and he's like actually physically fighting them
and doing I'm like this is what messes me up yeah
know that's great for a first time watch it throws
us off the SC but also I'm like yeah but we're are
you also an actor as your character right because
he doesn't it's yeah that's that all of that is
like oh even when you're sitting down to write
the script you're like it may not make total sense
yell to his work he does but um it makes it better
obviously for the story for the audience I have no
doubt there were a rare group of people that might
have guessed that it might have been yeah Mark
Ruffalo and off to you people but I got to imagine
it was a rare rare few but still that's um again I
I really did enjoy it but again my favorite part
of this film besides that twist was watching the
camaraderie and The Chemistry Between the four
of them I thought they all did such a great job
and I loved all their interactions and the way
they worked with each other and the way they got
comfortable with each other too like even when
he's like just the simple interaction when they
were in the elevator he's like you know in all the
in the year we worked together I just want to say
uh I thought you were a dick and uh yeah that's
it I just little interactions like that just I
get invested in car in character interactions like
that and again I just thought they all had such
great chemistry and I loved watching them again
work together and I also love scenes to when they
were like wait how did they do that thing with the
safe and I I like that instead of talking about it
they showed us how they came up with these schemes
and I thought it was just fun the way they do it
in a nonlinear way oh yeah how they tied like
the the mirror thing with the rabbit to the to
the case thing in the big like thing you're like
oh my God okay and again it's also for like when
you come to rewatch for a second third or fourth
time like for shading okay this is cool except you
don't know to look for that big of a foreshadow
in one little instance of of a trick right totally
but I think that's why we thought the or at
least why I thought the foreshadowing was her
playing with cards on the plane with Mark ruffo's
character being like is she trying to throw him
off some scent and make herself look like I'm
learning but like she knows everything like
that that also was a thing where I was like any
little thing in here is it foreshadowing which is
probably their their ploy to be like yeah you're
going to think it's everything else except for
the one thing that you're staring at the entire
time during this movie I don't know if it would
warrant an actual I mean I know they made a sequel
which I don't know anything about um if this is
obviously uh gets a good number of views obviously
I assume we're going to do a reaction but um point
I'm making is I even I was very fascinated and um
obviously I as mentioned many times I love that
twist with Mark Ruffalo I'd be very fascinated
even if they showed a flashback I don't need like
per se a whole movie of just with Morgan Freeman's
character and Mark ruffo's father Elias CZ in
terms of what what right how did we get here yeah
like I mean I just I was actually very and again
I was most fascinated about just what was going
on with our four main characters and Mark Ruffalo
the Chase and all that stuff cuz just it was so
mesmerizing all that all that fun stuff and all
the magic just throw magic I'm entertained um but
uh I mean yeah if you give me even um I I don't
know if it's going to be necessary now you see me
too because I don't have no idea what the plot is
in that film but I even if it was in this film
which again was not necessary but I would would
have definitely been intrigued if even it was like
a 5 10 minute scene where if they would have just
just Vis us a little more foundation between
Morgan and the dad just just so I could have
had just a little bit of a visual again even with
the dialogue that they gave me that was definitely
enough this is not a criticism it's just something
like I would have loved to have seen yeah well it
gives us that payoff more right because you're
saying if you saw that Foundation set up feel
Mark feel his revenge more I still felt it but
I would have felt it even more I kind of did but
not really until the end and I went and we went oh
now we see the connection which yes you would you
would want to like kill those people or mess them
up right Morgan's character bad enough I I would
be like I mean again I still was on Mark ruffo's
side in terms of I get where he's coming from and
I would totally like if I that were me in his
position I would totally want Morgan Freeman in
there for the rest of his natural life but if you
show it to me it's like I'm so on board with you
I'm get him in that jail Cale like show me the dad
dying in the in the safe in the ocean and then the
kid there and he's lonely and he's now without a
dad like it show us a little bit I mean that's the
beginning of every Disney movie right parent dies
kids left alone we're all like Weeping at the end
because of the foundation they've set up out of
subject question I'm very curious so Elias CZ who
of course played the great Casey Jones and Turtles
teen Ninja Turtles one and three he plays Mark
ruff father as we see in the newspaper clipping
there uhhuh how much does he get paid just for a
newspaper clipping of his photo like I'm just
curious how much do you get paid for I I guess
if your face is in there I mean you're not going
to get you're not getting nothing you're getting
something for that something I don't know how
much that would be though that'd be uh whatever
they offered I mean if it's more than it's I
mean still whatever you get it's like here's
a picture here's some money here you go that's
awesome either I wonder that's a good question
son of the gross thank you very much I doubt it
it works for me like he didn't do any work he's
like here's a head shot from 1979 you guys can use
that yeah overall though I I had a blast with this
movie it was a lot of fun um there's a reason it's
7.2 on IMDb and it has almost like 4.5 Stars this
movie is wildly entertaining it moves really quick
it has good dialogue and it constantly keeps you
guessing which I really enjoy and there's I mean
a lot of these movies I feel like I'm not I'm we
can be somewhat ahead we're like ah we really
saw that coming without like telling you guys
that and this one I was I was just guessing I was
throwing [__] at the wall you guys heard and I
was not right in any of that well that's one of
my biggest pet peeves is when I'm able to predict
things and I know sometimes I get criticized for
that in the comments like stop predicting stop
spoiling things just enjoy it's like that's one
of the things I like doing is predicting things
not he likes to spoil yes I know sorry guys no I
it's it's it's not that I like it's just sometimes
I just and again it's it's hard writing for sure
I get it I've tried to attempt to do and I suck
at it I I'll admit it uh it's very difficult to
write so um I I just like playing the prediction
game but on this on the flip side that's one of my
pet peeves I hate being able to predict things so
when something is able to really get me on a Twist
I'm genuinely happy to when I see it oh yeah and I
mean the thing is you guys know when you watch
so many movies and so much TV and you golf so
much media you kind of see twists and turns coming
you're just like they're just following tropes of
a thing this movie just didn't follow any tropes
I've seen before and made it wildely entertaining
with really good actors that I believe that were
like grounded the my biggest pet peeve which I
you guys have heard me say if I don't believe
the actors then I kind of I'm like I'm out the
illusion it breaks yeah it's like I can't I can't
handle that and the guys were great super grounded
everyone in it awesome awesome awesome great
casting which I always uh very much appreciate
um yeah I would give it out of 10 I'm G to go for
like an an eight an eight out of 10 I would maybe
even go like 8.5 thank you we've I was going to
say I'm going for an eight so we can't have the
same score yeah I'll put it I'll put it up to
an 8.5 because I thought this was just it was
a blast like I would have this is a lot of fun I
would have loved to be having like some whiskey
I would and watch this so that anytime Mar R's
like I'm getting a drink I'd be like me too if
they would have showed me that flashback scene it
would have been I'm just kid uh no no no but I'll
go with an eight that's still a high score so yeah
maybe it's in the second one who knows maybe they
set the foundation there okay then if they put it
in the second one I'll go back to an 8.5 for this
one but okay well well well he's moving he seems
like a Fickle guy right he's back and forth on it
depending upon if they set the foundation or not
exactly that's exactly how I am okay well I mean
I think those are our last thoughts you guys
need to put in the comments number one just be
like hey you're cool tell tell me if you like
my new t-shirt it's big it's oversized it says
Los Angeles with a cool car on it gives me a Miami
Vice type of feel I like it like9 maybe it's 80s I
don't know I don't know what anything from 80s or
90s I was born obviously in 2005 look at my face
um any last words just uh Batman man I'm Batman
uh no just uh this like I said this was a fun
Entertain Me Entertain Me Entertain entertaining
film uh edge of your seat fun twist or good twist
rather uh fun characters and like you said really
grounded and and Magic entertaining film I really
enjoyed stuff we had a blaster Ro we love you
guys and we'll see you on the next one [Music]
bye